now to some news that will definitely
get people excited one of reality TVs
favorite couples Ashley and Jarrod
revealed their wedding is just six
months away and we joined them along
with Evan and Carly at a possible
honeymoon hotspot when we teamed up with
secrets resorts and spas for a week of
elegant amenities and unlimited luxury
welcome to the preferred club bar so
this place is gorgeous overlooking the
ocean you've got the pool here and we
wanted to play a little game with you
guys called secrets at secrets we're
gonna see how well you know your partner
which one of you in the relationship
loves being on TV more Carly wrote that
down right away 1 2 3
excellent across the board of waiting
answers why did Evan love them Evan
likes attention and Jared why did Ashley
loved being on TV because Ashley loves
who shows more PDA go you guys on the
same page a tie everybody write down how
many kids do you plan on having three
two one no one to seven Oh Evan one
seven know Carly's Cavanaugh do I feel
like Lauren slowly getting under our
skin we promise no drama guys so you all
did great there's no winners we just win
brain
cheers to keeping secrets
[Music]